justement en parlant de jean michel
regarder alors qu'à les cas les sétois
commun jean michel et jean michel on est
vrai c'est vrai ça ça c'est
révolutionnaire ce que je vous dise ce
dangereux ou pas jean michel c'est
révolutionnaire
oui c'est pas pour moi c'est pas à ses
cheveux oui mais oui bah oui bah il fait
tellement chaud sur le bâton va perdre
verona d'aveyron franchement il fait
très très chaud
voilà peut-être ce n est même pas à ces
accords et on a fait ça a été incroyable
on est en direct auront pertes chaque
jour 6 7 qui croient qu'on a trouvé la
recette miracle pour lutter contre la
calvitie
[Applaudissements]
il ya des chercheurs qui aurait trouvé
un traitement miracle contre la calvitie
ce qu'ils n'ont pas et papa trouver un
come back c'est un contrôle qu on a
plutôt fait plusieurs morts des shows et
le mec il a dû être comme ça l'âge de la
coiffure et c'est bon on est sauvés du
coc vide non là c'est bon y aura plus de
choquer ce à quoi on a près de chez avec
sa peau contre corolla virus c'est vrai
beaucoup plus d'argent à se faire dans
la biosphère cheveux que pour ça le
cheveu aujourd'hui le cheveu le cheveu
le cheveu moyens il ya quoi
c'est quoi le jeu vous allez regarder le
récap vous allez arriver devant leur
télé qui certes sur la dernière fois
qu'ils avaient pendant le confinement
le truc qu'il essayait de cacher c'était
son double menton et sa calvitie
voilà et ben maintenant il aura plus à
cacher sa calvitie arthur parce que ça y
est elles ont trouvé le traitement
miracle - heureusement j'ai mon père mon
père quand on voit de dos on croit que
c'est un arbuste
vous êtes un homme cette info va
peut-être changer votre vie les cellules
souches pourraient être la solution
ultime pour lutter une bonne fois pour
toutes contre la calvitie phénomène
particulièrement développée chez les
hommes perdre ses cheveux est pour
beaucoup un crève coeur mais aujourd'hui
des chercheurs canadiens serait à deux
doigts de trouver la solution pour
lutter contre ce phénomène selon un
professeur de l'université de calgary
laboratoire qui mène cette étude les
souris qui perdent leurs poils et les
humains qui deviennent sourds présente
le même fait deux types et ça tombe bien
puisque ce sont précisément sur des
souris que ces tests ont été menés et il
semble fonctionner c'est en régénérant
les fibroblastes qui se trouve à la base
de chaque follicules capillaires que ces
chercheurs ont bon espoir de mettre un
point final à la chute des cheveux
si ce traitement pourrait stopper cette
chute pour le moment encore difficile de
dire s'il pourrait permettre à ceux qui
ont déjà perdu leurs cheveux de
retrouver la chevelure de leur vingtaine
en tous les cas ces résultats
encourageants de l'espoir bref la
science est donc à un cheveu de sauver
les hommes c'est la grille attendez là
j'ai raté un truc ils font ça sur des
souris l'epo il ya des souris chaude qui
voulaient pécho cédé pour ses souris
elles sont à jour oui bah oui moi je
suis fan des sourds et j'en ai toujours
eu depuis chez petit nom c'est vrai et
quand elles vieillissent à le perdre
leurs poils surtout dans le bas du dos
et à je trouve ça dégueulasse vous et à
vous les souris s'avoue néanmoins les
mois d'été où la peur domestica c'était
trop mignonne c'était noires et blanches
des petits tours vous n'aimez pas ça les
rongeurs ça va mieux ça va bien que
rongeurs dont les enfants si j'ai su que
je suis d apprivoiser
ah ouais ouais comment quoi vous avez
fait comment pas courir au mont rouge un
peu ils vous ont créé tout y est oui oui
bon ça oui ou parler d' arthur tout à
l'heure et petit train parce que c'est
lui qui l'a dit oui ça il a dit chez
anne roumanoff que le il a dit que
pendant le confinement ici de quelques
petites infos médias on a testé aussi un
médicament contre le double menton sur
les bogdanoff ça n'a pas marché
[Rires]
or 25 vrai problème c'est sympa vous
personne n'a compris à la vanne
d'isabelle orvin de chez l'homme c'est
un vrai problème la peur la peur la peur
d'un jeu blanc un vrai problème la perte
des chandelles à deux problèmes la perte
des cheveux et la perte direction c'est
les deux problèmes qui déstabilisait que
vous mangez les deux là et vous avez les
lâchant princesse des vélos le prince
harry a reçu un traitement pour lutter
contre la calvitie
depuis son mariage avec mag la call girl
ces sacrifices y est depuis son mariage
avec ben bernanke en un an sont
qu'albicy avait doublé n'ont quasiment
mort c'est lié à la même et ceux de
fixation souvent des soucis c'est jouer
à son père sont tous ses moyens sur son
père il est que des pommes est comme ça
les cas motivés ça vous dérange un homme
chauve ou beinheim pas du tout c'est
vrai mais bon la regarder des zones
statham je trouve assez reste audible
vous à bruce moussavou 0 je pense que
c'est quand même très important que
quand on perd des cheveux faute ou
radiation aura bien se passer si on
garde le bandeau ici bien sûr beaucoup
font tous les tons rabat les wallabies
auront du range
moi je ferais mais je suis comme kelly c
a pas tout le monde mon père si je veux
c'est mieux de tout temps marie
découpant du crâne moi je le crains beau
crâne roger en train d'en point de six
races mais schultz a pas valu sainte et
les chemises